welcome to this meeting on the council's
proposed investment in the city block
development project my name is Rex
Chapman those who don't know me and I've
been asked by the council tonight to
cheer this public meeting usual
housekeeping notes first of all toilets
are located in the foyer outside the
Victoria rooms on the left hand side
this exits that are well marked and the
unlikely event of an emergency
a siren will sound an announcement will
be made to evacuate the building please
use those exits and if there is such an
emergency where to congregate on the
grass here in front of Sir John's Church
and finally just as a courtesy to the
speakers
can you please ensure that your cell
phones are turned off for the duration
of this meeting now the meeting itself
is being recorded audio end video and
the purpose of that is to enable that to
be shown to those people who may not be
able to make it this evening but in a
moment I'll introduce council CEO clear
Headley is going to together with Andrew
Cameron a GM of hull Co going to give a
presentation outlining exactly what the
council is proposing but before doing so
I just want to tell you something about
the consultation process itself the
council has produced a consultation
document which sets out the details
behind the decision
the council has in front of it on the
proposed investment and the inner city
block no decisions had been made by the
Council of Elders further involvement in
the project and the purpose of this
consultation that the council is now
undertaken is it to enable that to hear
from you the community to enable you to
have your say about the project and the
council's proposed investment the
council is inviting the public to make
submissions on the proposal which are to
be received by Friday the 28th of June
you don't have to wait that long if
you've got a view tonight please put
your submission in once those
submissions are received by their
clothes
date council will consider these written
submissions and provided an opportunity
for submitters to speak to them at a
hearing which is likely to be scheduled
in the week of the 15th of July a
decision by the Council on the
investment in the inner city block
project will most likely be made in
August 2000 and 19 and that decision
will be influenced by what the community
has to say and this public meeting make
marks the start of that consultation
process at the conclusion of the
presentation by clear and Andrew there
will be an opportunity for questions and
I'm sure there will be a number of them
and those questions are encouraged it's
an important part of the consultation
process that the council hear from you
and be in a position to answer those
questions that I'm sure that you all
have so with that I'm going to hand the
floor over to clear thank you can I
start by saying a big thank you to
everyone for showing up tonight
I know it's brisk out there and just to
contrast that we've got the heating on
really warm so please take your jackets
off if you think that you are in danger
of overheating there are some seats at
the front here for those of you at the
back who might like the opportunity to
be more comfortable while we go through
the material I'm going to start by
asking Andrew here on my left and rumors
as Rex have said the general manager of
Hulk Oh Hulk who represents Council as
the shareholder if you like in HW CP and
Andrew has been studying the material
he'll start the presentation by giving
you some background and some facts about
the proposal and then I'll cover off
some matters from counsels perspective
Thank You Claire and welcome everyone we
thought it was probably best to start
with just a bit of a background for
those people who haven't been involved
with like counsel has in counsel staff
in terms of the history of how we got to
where we are today and the decision that
counsel has been asked to make so in
essence the concept around HW CP limited
really evolved out of the swords process
and I don't know how many of you are
familiar with the swords process but
they came up with a number of what they
call transformational projects which
they thought would assist him ACOG will
achieve its objective of basically
growing 10,000 people and a number of
other objectives one of those objectives
was around the revitalization of the
inner city and in coming up with that
strategy in that project they recognized
that one of the issues that would be
confronted in any attempt to do that was
the fragmentation of the ownership of
the inner city so that it was difficult
to get substantial sized land holding
that would enable a major tenant for one
of a better description to move back
into the inner city so that was one of
the issues that were forefront when H
wcp was created so once it was created
council through its subsidiary company
in Kabul city property limited was
requested to invest in H wcp limited for
the purposes of basically consolidating
the inner city consolidating the land
holding to enable a significant tenant
to move back in following development as
part of that process the the decision
was made to basically invest in HW super
limited for the purposes land banking
creating the land and then transferring
the land to a developer for the
development to occur now what was
identified as part of that process and
one of the issues that does arise as
part of that process obviously the
resource around the resource consent and
the resource around demolition so that
when you're looking at
developing his site it's much easier to
do what they call a greenfield site a
site where there is no prior buildings
there is nothing else to be done
obviously the inner city has a lot of
buildings has a lot of work things that
would need to be demolished before you
could start the rebuild so there's a
risk that developers don't really like
around that htw CP has effectively taken
that risk through the resource consent
in the agreement to demolish the
properties and it's at that stage that I
shall be super limited is looking to
transfer the land to a developer in
order to enable a to cook to occur and
that is what this consultation in
essence is about so the new ending
in essence will take over some of the
land and I'll get to that in the next
slide it's not developing the whole city
block and council has not been asked to
invest in the development of the whole
city block it's only to been asked to
invest in part of it so a new entity
will be formed which will have a number
of different shareholders investors in
whatever form they end up taking some of
those will be public some of those will
be private and it will purchase the land
at a price obviously from hwc P limited
for the purposes of doing that the rough
well the working figure around the
development costs is one hundred and
eighty million dollars that's the best
estimate at this stage it may go up it
may go down but that's the working
figure that's been used the balance of
the block will still remain with a
shovel you see P limited so infocar will
see the property and the council through
that structure will retain an interest
in the block and HW super limited will
continue to try and find developers for
the portions of the block that are not
being developed by this new entity that
councils been asked to investing to give
some context to that this is a slide
which shows basically the block I think
they've wanted to be part just so you'll
be seeing that the grayed out areas but
I think everyone would know it well an
hour
realize that there's the Kelvin hotel
which HT wcp limited doesn't own there's
the reading cinema center that it
doesn't own but basically the balance of
the block he's either owned or under
contract ohw CP limited the area that
he's not great at being what's marked on
their stages 1 2 & 3 is the development
that counsel has been asked to invest in
the other developments will occur well
may occur but if they do occur it will
be by a different entity a third party
that isn't related to the council or HW
CP and that's pretty much now we've got
the where we are that's about all there
is today thank you
so counsels
asking you about the investment that
it's been asked to make and we've been
asked to invest 20 million dollars the
material that you have refers to 30
million dollars and that's because we
are asking you now how do you feel about
us investing in this project recognizing
that sometimes things change I'm sure
you can all think of a council project
that has needed a change to its budget
and we thought it would be more open and
correct to say from the beginning we may
need a little bit more so we are asking
you about an investment of 20 million
but we have added to that a five million
dollar contingency fund
in addition council is saying we should
put some funds aside just in case when
we sit down with major wcp and look at
the details of the design there is
anything we want to change and that's
the reason for the other five million
dollars that we're asking you about so
the request from H wcp has been 420
million but we're asking for five as a
contingency on the budget and five to
recognize that there may be things
that the council feels if it is going to
invest it should alter slightly the
impact on rate pass we estimate will be
1.2 percent and bets on a 20 million
dollar investment we've again forecast
that the servicing costs of 20 million
would be approximately $600,000 per year
what does that mean for our debt level
and what does that mean for other
projects it will take our debt levels up
and it will mean that we will need to
carefully manage our projects but there
has been some preliminary modeling done
which shows that we can afford to invest
in city block and deliver every other
project that is currently in the long
term plan provided we prioritize and
stage those over the 10 20 years a heat
we're asking new about investing and
city block and that's where council is
taking a role as an investor council
where's a number of different hats in
the community and council has some other
obligations because it is also the asset
owner of the road and the footpaths and
what we refer to as the city scape now
if this development was being done by
anybody else
if Westfield had come to town and said
we're going to build something here
council would have been responsible for
addressing the cityscape around the
development and you may recall that
there was a piece of work done and
started an under Carol CBD the council
staff and counselors refer to it as the
Pocock report and that was the work that
started the beautification works and
esque Street we had put aside six
million dollars in the long term play
already we now estimate that the total
budget for that should be in the region
of 20 million dollars so we would need
to add another 14 million to our LTP
budgets but there has been some funding
for that already we're not asking for
your views on that because that is part
of the investment that we would make as
asset owner so I guess one of the
questions that you might ask is why are
we consulting now and that's in the
context of the consent process has gone
through one of the things that HW CP has
certainly observed as the private sector
and the public sector work at two
different paces we do need your feedback
to be able to make a decision on an
investment we in looking at why we are
considering investing the government has
just put that what we refer to us for
for well-beings back into the local
government act and ruin referred to the
fact that when the regional development
strategy for Southland was developed a
transformational project for the CBD was
identified and doing a development like
this was seen as one of the leading
transformational projects in that
strategy one of the questions that you
may ask is what happens of the resource
consent is declined
well what often happens with consent
applications when they are declined is
that the applicant lodges an appeal and
then starts mediations so I think that
it would be fair to say there would be
some negotiation would take place what
we have at the moment is a proposal that
we have some clarity from HW CP on what
they are asking for and we are looking
for your feedback what would happen if
council doesn't invest we know that
there are
other potential investors who are
looking for counsel to put its money in
its community in the assets in the CBD
and we know that people want to see
change in the CBD what we have is some
certainty or potential certainty in
front of us or a period of uncertainty
in front of us so again I come back and
say we're looking for your feedback
submissions close on the 28th of June
that can seem like a long time away
Rex made the comment that don't be shy
about putting your submission and now I
guess what I want to say is don't
consider putting it off and thinking
that I'll do it tomorrow because you can
always put in an additional comment but
it would be a terrible thing to get to
July and think I mean - I went out on a
cold night and attended a public meeting
and I meant to make my views known but I
missed the opportunity so please put
your submission and now material is
available it was being handed out as you
arrived it's available on the web we
will be getting out to a place near you
to further engage and we're happy to
answer your questions tonight thanks
very much thanks very much Peter and
Andrew look that's a very good summary
of the proposal obviously this ability
now in the consultation document but
this would be sufficient in net to I'm
sure prompt some questions from our
audience
it's an excellent turnout tonight and I
think it reflects the fact that you know
this is one of the biggest decisions
that a city has had to make for perhaps
a generation and it is great to see such
good public participation at this early
stage so clear and Andrea your some
questions I think do we have some
microphones that are going to be taken
to the speaker so if you have a question
can you please raise your hand and we'll
get a microphone to you
thank you
hello hi hi Nathan Surendran it is a
period of uncertainty ahead as a CEO
says and it's probably about the only
thing I agree with her on and it's my
contention that proposed redevelopment
there's nothing to reduce that period of
uncertainty I think that the work of the
the sword's developer was strategically
flawed it didn't really take a realistic
view of the future it's very much 19th
or 20th century thinking and we are now
in the 21st century a 50% contingency
that you're asking for 30 million on the
20 million desk you know that's a that's
a big contingency I was involved in
quite a few central London office and
retail redevelopment projects but is a
professional engineer in the UK and the
typical uncertainty contingencies ran to
him about 10 15 % so there's a
significant risk associated with this
for the right payers and also you know
what happens if this doesn't invest in
this document you've handed us at the
door there it says that you know the
council will be left with intelligent
and talented space but you don't
actually put a number to the size of
that liability so you know there's some
and some questions that really are
unanswered here I wanted to make which
was what oh yeah and the other major
player in this redevelopment work is the
hwr group and obviously they've put a
lot of efforts and money into getting
the project to this stage again in terms
of the potential benefit that were being
asked to fund to the hwr group through
the ratepayer contribution to the
development and I'm wondering what what
is
actual upside for them and is that money
in some way going to be distributed back
to the right pair clearly obviously you
know there's the other it was about jobs
and so on but I mean actual funds may
develop for other purposes thank you
[Applause]
tonight can I start by addressing the
matter of contingency risk and can I say
to you that we could have asked how you
felt about 20 million and left it at
there and then if there had been a
change and there had been a need for
funders to find some contingency funding
we would have needed to come back to you
and counsel felt that it was more honest
to be at the beginning to say that there
was a need to create some contingency
funding now what that amount will be we
hope it'll be zero I can tell you that
there are people on the team that are
emphatic it will be zero but I can also
say that we all know that things change
so it is it is not an indication from
the beginning that we do not feel
positive about this it's an indication
that we recognize that to invest we need
your feedback and so we should make that
a one-shot factor the second thing I
would say is that only 5 min of it is
contingency I want to be very clear
about that the other 5 million is in
case the council determines that as an
investor it would like to see some
change and the own the nearest analogy I
can give you is if you're building a
house or doing renovations and halfway
through you recognize that there is
something that would improve it and the
council recognized that as an investor
that may happen and again it felt it was
better to say that now and to seek your
feedback on that point
then to ask you for 20 million and then
come back and say oops so if I can
consider that point addressed Rex I see
it yes yes so look the second question
that was raised plea or Andrew was that
if the proposal doesn't proceed then the
council will have liability for the
untenanted space that the council will
be 52 think shareholder of the asset of
the city block can I say to you it is
very very unusual to find land that has
been aggregated to this degree if this
proposal did not go ahead in its current
form
I'm confident something else would go
forward but what we have in front of us
today is the development that we're
considering we haven't looked at the
liability if it did not go ahead because
we are we think that's further down the
track and the third question I think I
can answer they speak the speaker asked
whether or not that there was some
upside for hwr will that be
redistributed to the community and
that's not a question that the council
can answer if hwr is a shareholder in
the entity that undertaken the
development then it will share in the
benefits and the risks of that
development as will the council and I
just like to add to the question around
the contingency the 190 million that I
mentioned earlier has you're staying at
10% contingency in it there are a number
of other factors outside the normal
building contingency issues that still
need to be resolved and much like the
five million dollars allocated to
potential changes to design or
improvements down the tract those
numbers are around other risks outside
your normal build contingency risks
thanks Andrew do we have another
question
I'm sorry my name is Michael Wilson I'm
a trustee of Community Trust south the
Community Trust has been approached as
well for funding em it's being looked at
at the moment one thing that we observed
and which came out at the resource
consent hearings is that in fact this
isn't really a commercial investment at
all it's got a very significant
philanthropic aspect to it and so while
it will be an investment that will
require 180 million from the investors
to put it in its most simple form
because of the return the original
return and whatnot it will be
immediately and appear in this because
we'll only be worth 90 million after
it's been constructed now you know what
what exactly the whys and wherefores our
ball rotation those are all big figures
and the rest of it the fact of the
matter is that the yes to at least two
of the other investors have made it very
clear that this is and has a very
significant philanthropic aspect to it
and not a commercial one now I was
waiting for this presentation to raise
this point and it hasn't and first of
all I wondered why and second of all the
question that obviously the Community
Trust will have to think about but I
want what's the council's view of this
is will we get the money back from our
investment
we contemplated and it's clear that
people use terminology in many different
ways so when we talk about a commercial
investment simplistically so that
everyone's on a similar sort of page
when I talk about that you're talking
about effectively your cost of
investment and cost of borrowing and you
might say six to eight percent if you're
getting that sort of return of Barbaria
costs you might say that's a commercial
investment there is no doubt that this
investment will not be giving that level
of return but by the same token it will
not be losing money so we'll be covering
the costs of investment it just won't be
a commercial return on top of the costs
of investment obviously on the
projections we dealt with it from a
counsels perspective in terms of trying
to be upfront about the impact on rates
acknowledging that from counsels
perspective we do not see a cash return
within the first properly ten years and
so when we're not trying to effectively
dress it up for community and saying
look there's a return here we won't be
after that there won't be an impact on
rates because we'll be getting our money
back we would expect the business will
be adding in by you there will be cash
flow coming in but that will be being
used to either pay back banks or other
funders who have different requirements
around getting their cash back out of
the investment so I don't think it's
quite fair to say that it's not a return
that will or an investment that will be
giving you a return you just need to be
clear on that the other thing is the
question around an impairment and really
obviously I haven't seen the advice your
if we've got advice that comes up with
that sort of figure impairments really
an accounting issue rather than a
long-term investment issue and counsel
is really looking at this as a long-term
investment we're looking at at ten years
plus yes if there becomes a commercial
the ability to exit we would consider
that but we don't see it come of those
commercial levels a return within that
time impairment would be a book entry
which from a counsels perspective would
be acknowledged but has no impact on the
cash flow to counsel or anything like
that thanks Andrew Cleo noted in the
consultation document that counsel was
proposing that this investment is being
made for strategic reasons and it's an
investment in the development in the
development for the social and economic
well-being of the community rather than
purely for commercial returns is that
something that you want to comment on or
expand upon in relation to this question
look I think that my comment would be
that council sees the need for it to be
involved in it for exactly that
strategic purpose that's been discussed
where they you put that into strategic
reasons or philanthropic reasons that
the other part of the comment that I
would make is there with no disrespect
to the two businessman have been driving
this I don't think there's many same
businessman that would get so involved
in driving something because it's been a
huge challenge and I don't think they're
doing it for commercial return at all
they're very clear they're doing it for
the good of an mcCargo you also asked
about where the council would get its
money back and again in the back of the
document there's a recognition that
council would be looking to hold this
investment for the long term but as it
does with all of its investments it may
consider holding the cost of holding or
what it would do in the longer term
thanks clear does that answer your
question or do we have another question
thank you
all right speed stacks re fifty to fifty
three thousand is the current population
and point six and that doesn't include
students living here actual rate paying
but no the population is all of the
people who are usually resident and in
the kernel I'm just trying to establish
what the future cost will be to our
rates and fourteen years time without
the growth that you're expecting on top
of the usual rate increases that happen
every year plus the interest rates start
to climb there but whichever seemed
everything starts to compound and if we
don't get you rate payers and the city
then falls back on the right path again
and again just
escalations because we agreed by bad so
that's my first question second question
why were the tenants actually all
affected from the building's prior to
any decisions being made
okay thank you please just before I get
you to answer that question we've hit an
important message there's a car with its
lights on in the council car parked at
the registration plate if I can read
this correctly is su VI is the carpet
car registration number so if that's
yours you might want to pop out turn the
lights off thank you now fear two
questions here what is the cost of this
investment over time well the the
figures that we've projected would
suggest that the cost to a rate payer
whether a round of $2,000 rates per
would be around $25 per rate payer on
the cost of the loan
[Music]
so for those of you on the back of the
room there's a question about the
escalation of rates in general and then
the impact of the Slone on top of that
and the answer that I would give to that
is that council operates within its own
benchmarks for rates increases so it
would then have to manage its finances
carefully to ensure that the capital
programs that it was starting the other
capital projects that was doing were
managed evenly over the years carefully
over the years so that the rates and
increases did not fall outside of those
benchmarks
and the budget
so there's a bit more of a question
about I think about where the council
could manage the other projects that it
has on the LTP and the answer to that is
yes the answer is that on the modeling
we have done and and the project of the
museum was mentioned on the modeling we
have done the museum could be afforded
and the investment and the city block
could be afforded we would need to
prioritize those along with other
capital projects that we do and we
believe and we've shown to the council's
that we can do that prioritization and
still meet our budget benchmarks the the
rates will increase as they are
projected in the LTP thanks clear now
the second question was why were the
tenants evicted look I think that that's
probably outside the scope of this
consultation on this investment proposal
but it certainly I'm gonna try and I'm
gonna try and answer it just making the
point that's probably outside of the
scope of of the this consultation I'm
not sure whether or not either Andrew or
clear would be able to answer that but
I'm going to ask whether or not they are
in a position to do so imagine is
probably quite a complicated question
answer I'm not familiar with the project
management at the beginning of the
project looking simplistically it's a
decision that was made you run a risk
one way or the other obviously having no
tenants in the building makes it easier
when you do get your consent to progress
with your demolition
quickly as possible leaving tenancy then
that gives you a risk that you can't do
that as quickly as you might like it's a
decision that was my for commercial
reasons in essence
you know I really I applied together
[Music]
we knew on a production that
[Music]
so for the people of the the speaker has
questioned the the timing of asking
tenants to leave the space and the inner
city block before resource consent end
and this consultation has been completed
is it right the question the question
was asked as to whether it was always
intended that there would be a public
process which I take to be both around
the consent and also around your
investment and the answer to that is a
categorical yes the consent process
always had to be notified and similarly
for an investment of the size your
feedback was always going to be sought
some tenants will have made their own
choices
the project was always under the control
of HW CP and they've made a decision as
they were able to do about timeframes
but they chose possibly knowing that
some would take longer than others to
find other accommodation but I think
we've given them access bikinis I mean
you may question the wisdom of of taking
that action before the resource consent
process and the consultation process has
been completed but I don't think that
answer can't be given as to why there
was why there occurred at this meeting
in the we connect space in the last
couple days it's almost heartbreaking to
read about the people that you've got
nowhere to go
and when I said to do with food another
one as a here drip mail here do sir and
as a sports place in our sickness
and they've just got nowhere to go even
though they've tried and they're almost
so stressed out and heartbroken that
it's happened and it's just unfortunate
it makes I'd say a lot of the ones that
read that magazine
will be why say it for them is people
will as well sitting here tonight it
will look think if they don't look I
think everyone in the room would
appreciate that trying to manage a
project like this is difficult there's
going to be dislocation of tenants and
that's always going to be very very
difficult but I don't think that we're
going to be able to solve those problems
tonight the purpose of this consultation
is really to get your feedback on the
proposed investment by the council and
to the next phase of the project which
is the development itself and so thanks
Claire
hello if there is a budget overrun and
if we have to defer some other council
projects what is most likely to be
deferred have you kind of made like a
list of priorities and the other things
that are most likely to be bout thank
you there has been no consideration of
projects being banked because as I've
explained we have done preliminary
modeling that shows that we are able to
afford if we program the work we can
take the the pigs and troughs of our
funding requirements out and we can even
then across and we can deliver all of
the projects and the long term plan and
this investment
just in the paper here page number 10
other council projects would need to be
deferred under the disadvantages
so this is why I'm asking discretion so
in the bottom here proposed option to
invest up to 30 million in the city
block development and under
disadvantages the second one it says
other council projects would need to be
deferred so which ones there has been no
consideration of other projects being
deferred it would be if we didn't put
that in the document as a possible
disadvantage
we'd be accused of not thinking about it
but the work we've done shows that we
can manage all of that we recognize that
things change that is a potential
disadvantage but nothing has changed at
this point if things change that would
be a matter for the council of the day
yes I think that the note on page 10
probably is just a recognition that
there's always an opportunity cost if
you spend some money somewhere then it's
money that's not available somewhere
else but I think via what you're saying
that there is no specific protein that
is likely to Marcel
we have a question from speaker down the
bed testing so I think we'll take the
one down the back first and then come
back to you soon sorry sorry can you
just put the microphone up better place
what's the idea that I was against the
council spending here rates money for a
development my feeling on it was that if
it was really going to be a really good
opportunity for investment there private
investors would have done it in what
I've been hearing hasn't changed how I
feel about that at all I still don't
think the ratepayers should be paying
any more money into this development
because it is a commercial project in
looking at the paperwork that you've
given us and we get the round plan for
how it might look
we brought them up a magnifying glass so
I can't see what we're going to get for
our money so my feeling on it is still
no and what is she likely to ask for a
show of hands here if I'm allowed to for
how many people have been here and still
feel that it is know what everyone like
to show whether they think it should
still be not so there's not a percentage
of us that are not convinced that this
is going to be a bit of in specimen but
I'd also like to pass and this is
what's the benchmark for the rates
increase per year two questions there
and clear firstly the speaker asked this
was a commercial project and you recall
that there was a discussion at the
beginning of the questions about the
philanthropic nature or the strategic
nature of this investment the since
ended as an actuality that it doesn't
stand on its own commercial feet and it
does require other funders like council
to come into it and that is the reason
for the consideration by the council we
believe its strategic in addressing the
state of the CBD as it is at the moment
we believe that it would attract new
business it will certainly generate new
jobs and generate additional economic
projects in the surrounds of the city
block that's why council is looking for
the feedback on it but it does not stand
on its own feet from a commercial
perspective and the second question I
think was what was the benchmark what is
the benchmark for the rates increase
sorry I just go back a step because
Andrew also explained that this wasn't a
project that would lose money he talked
about the normal sort of percentage
required for a commercial project and
the requirement for the funding from
council to support particularly in the
first ten years but he was not saying
that it would be a non-performing asset
he was saying that it was not a
commercial asset in the way at a six to
eight percent return he said I'm sorry
the second question was what is the
benchmark for the rates increase say a
you meaning the the one I think
1.2% increases that it's based on the
current rates so what are two parts to
the answer that I would give you for the
rates increase the first is that council
has a policy and the policy in the LTP
talks about a percentage above the local
government cost index so there is a
flexibility in there recognizing what
the costs are around not just the CPI
that we are most familiar with but also
the cost index for local government over
the 10 years of the LTP that we are
currently in it's an average rates
increase of 3.1 percent per annum the
draft annual plan for next year proposes
something slightly less from there thank
you clear does that answer your question
you think you know the council doesn't
invest are there any other investors
they are gonna be followed up on because
if we don't invest there are other
projects that have found funding
elsewhere is that an option for the
project yeah could you just repeat that
thanks if this project doesn't proceed
you're asking no I'm asking that if the
council doesn't invest do the people
that are the management company that's
managing this now do they have a set of
other options where to get other funding
from I think the short answer to that is
no not at this time
sorry Mel
there are other potential funders that
are looking to follow councils lead and
would see
a lack of counsel investment as an
indicator that it should not be involved
either you're talking about them talking
about counsel support and showing the
support or investment correct
Thanks thanks very much now I think we
had a gentleman down here that wanted to
ask was she just the previous speaker
over there mention about the projects
that would be delayed by the council do
you have a young I know we had a slide
that potentially show that that what
would be what projects would be perhaps
left behind or delayed
and survey the work the council has done
to date would show that the council can
afford the projects set out in the LTP
and this investment
there has been no consideration given to
any delay or deferral of any projects in
the LTP
that's not what you're really saying
other council projects will be delayed
because of what are the council projects
will be delayed I don't think either
choice
sorry Freud might jump in I think there
might be some confusion terminology that
that's not a statement of fact it's an
identification of a risk that will need
to be identified and managed assuming
the decision to invest is made that
can't it's not a it's not a gift it's a
risk a risky something that might occur
if you take certain steps and so be
clear the visa services are identified
not a not a certainty of an event that
will occur I'm well acquainted with but
surely the council could identify what
projects may well be delayed and the
choice provided to the right place
it will look so I think clear has
already identified that there are
actually no projects currently
identified in the long term plan that
will need to be deferred or delayed if
this investment proposal proceeds I
think that's the purest answer
it's all negative to my man here it's
all just spin on the works and go the
other way macaque way I'm very proud
sailing very proud of them but coggle
but it's not brain surgery here guys if
you had a look at the scene from ACOG
lately like it's not flashes and people
say what people are moving out but
they're moving out because the buildings
are falling down now we know everyone in
the room knows have the two basic and
best desire it's not rocket science they
can go away and spend their money
elsewhere anywhere in New Zealand like I
leave it on the bank can make more money
but they're putting it under the Cargill
and I think that's very special but what
are you saying on the rights but to say
about $24 a is it roughly say some right
well that's a lot of money another $24
so you know
you know come on Gus its own for
catalyst be proud of the place thank you
I like talking out but I need to say
something here this is our city this is
our children and grandchildren we don't
do something for the city and make it
look better than what it does now then
where the hell are we gonna end up when
they do beep beep things don't put money
in what city
Danine do all sorts of things your rates
go up that's the reality of it this is
our city we should be working to make
the Sbisa tea we can possibly make that
means check you what we do and people
need to think of they add up and think
about the future so Jenna was just a
metro with the hand up all ready to go
here I'm in favor of this Toobin what
worries me is that cats are going to
give me your money off the top as it
happens and all of these bloody things
Richardson groups got a supply
everything the concrete and everything
else Akkad only many bit there thanks
sir yes sorry Greeks there wasn't a
question in there but but I do need to
say that there will be public
procurement processes applied to this
and that's part of the reason for the
separation between stages one two and
three and stages four five and six
stages one two and three is what you are
being asked to put money into they that
project will be managed to meet public
sector expectations in terms of
procurement and there will be times when
there will be conflicts are identified
and managed by the shareholders stages
four five and six we're not asking for
any public money and to be frank those
who are involved in it can manage it as
they choose but I do want to be very
clear that there's a separation and the
Sector standards will be adhere to what
we're there is public money thank you
we've got a number of hands up here so
we'll take questions on the slide now
things no it needs to be yeah so my
understanding is that you're investing
money to contribute towards against
beautifying the CBD with an
outward-looking proposal so far I think
the original design was perhaps accused
of being a little bit too inward looking
it helps a bit more light and perhaps
didn't take into consideration the you
know how it affected the surrounding
area and on a city scape perspective so
my question would be is how is does this
contribution ensure that this is an
outward-looking project as the benefit
of improving the CPD and do you have a
stronger say in that and the design by
investing okay I would start by asking
me by answering the into that question
and saying that if council is not an
investor then it can have no impact
whatsoever on the design of the
development if council is not an
investor it will still be responsible
for managing the roading asset and the
city scape factors and ensuring that
there is integration within the CBD if
council is an investor then it would
want to ensure that the development
encouraged people in through and out of
the development to the rest of the CBD
there has been a question as to where
the council would have a director on the
board the absolute shape of the new
entity has not yet been finally
determined so the representation of any
of the shareholders has not been
determined I could add to that that it
clearly any of the equity shareholders
have any anticipation and expectation
that they will have a director I think
you into another question at the back of
the room
hello I just got a quick question to the
counselors mainly in the people involved
and the people that are against that
than the people that are foreign just to
think about where you're sitting what
was us it was a better land some rump
the old wooden building on it and their
forefathers probably about a hundred
years ago built this facility that we're
sitting in right now now imagine what
the population was in about 3/4 of
nothing and look what they did so this
is a sort of courage that you need to
have today to make this project happen
and you only need a better thing for the
courage that they had to build this
building so that's all I've got to say
thank you
equation you thank you well thank you I
just had a couple questions it says this
is about increased community well-being
and growth rather than financial return
which I totally accept I don't think
there is a person in this room that does
not want to see Invercargill thrive that
doesn't want to see some sort of
development in a beautiful city
however we are facing a housing crisis
in this country we are facing a housing
crisis in Invercargill but I see no
residential housing in this
I see no aged care housing in this and I
see no Civic spaces I see no playgrounds
I see nothing for community groups like
the farmers market to set up every
weekend and I'm wondering where is the
the social community return for us can
you explain how that fits CBDs and
business districts are places they have
become places where people go for
leisure and recreation and the
development will have places where
people may choose to as I think they
refer to hang out spend time that
provides a sense of well-being a place
of focus for a community when you go to
a new town you want to know where the
Main Street is you want to know where
the town center is the challenge for
this and part of the reason for the city
scape work and the question from the
gentleman earlier about the the
projection of development in terms of
looking outwards is to ensure that it
has a place in the CBD and it
contributes to the CBD and its overall
that is the social well-being that we
are looking to address through
contributing to this development
thanks clear have another question
what sorry yes yep that's fine
I've driven down from Dunedin tonight
I'm a proud self and ER as well and just
a smeeting it's the first time I've come
down to a meeting at home before ever
I've been out of town for nearly 30
years I'm gonna ask you what is the
income of the average income of and the
Carroll ratepayers I can tell you that
some of that information had I mean I
could guess what the number is off the
top me because I've read it but I would
rather you know sorry excuse me
rather than guess I would suggest that
you look at the supporting material
which has some analysis around their
audience tonight in most of them if they
excuse me that mostly an elderly age and
so I probably thinking Dunedin as 20,000
that's the average income of Dunedin so
if you have a look at the supporting
material find those figures actually
included in there I think you have a
look at the NCI report he deals with
those figures for you in them and that
would be the answer to your question
well you guys must have some fairy
godmothers because if you're going to
pay out freaking we're only going to pay
$25 extra in your race I can tell you
what the stadium in Dunedin and now they
want to build a new shell on Harbor
you're the know where how these people
are going to be paying $25 or what the
extra and rates that's just excellent
rubbish and then the 30 million dollars
that's going to cost a beacon you're got
a budget that's be how much it will be
like it's not going to be nearly
it'll be more than there when tininess
City Council 530 million for the stadium
I mean what's your highest burger again
I suppose we answered that question
earlier in the presentation and had the
estimate around the build cost which is
180 million so that the information is
available yeah I think I think to be
fair assuming that the the cost of the
investment is thirty million dollars
then the council should be in an
accurate in a position to assess what
that is going to reflect in the in the
average rate increase and that's the
information that has been provided
gentlemen at the bed thank you
you're sitting at the back here
listening you know go back a few years
ago when we had the opportunity to
develop the inner city through a mall in
the same place and it was stalled and we
have today such an appalling block that
it's falling down the earthquake risk of
it and the needs strengthening by the
rioters of those buildings who can't
afford that we have an opportunity to
lift the standard of the city I have a
large number of visitors come to the
city and they have commonly stated to me
that the city looks ten teke
untidy and falling down now about Tom
south of us and Invercargill and I'm a
very proud South under as the time they
stood up and be leaders in the city and
begged the council and a vest honest
project so that everybody will wick the
benefits in time through economic divine
growth tourism to the town and
attraction of new businesses because we
modernize only our city so we need to
open our eyes and start looking at
what's best for the city
do we have another question I think
there's a hand up down the back Dean uh
uh hi I'm Cherie C of the Chamber of
Commerce I just wanted to say you know
sitting here listening same as comments
it's what Dave's just made us you know
how exciting is this we're sitting here
on the cusp of truly transforming our
city and now from a chamber point of
view where the voice of over 400 local
businesses and this redevelopment is
going to increase our GDP it's going to
generate over 500 jobs during the
rebuild then offer another 300 permanent
jobs in retail and of course contribute
towards the tourism you know we need
this but we need everyone to be bold in
in the thinking to create create the
outcome that we all want so I think it's
time for us to step up and take
ownership of their future also the
alternative is not an option the CBD
can't stay and the current stated as the
majority the buildings are earthquake
proof we're not going to get new
business investment coming in to those
buildings so basically it's not an
option you know as a community we can't
just sit back and wait for the
inevitable to happen so just aging or
south unders basically to submit and you
know I think that it's a great
investment for our council and I think
we get on board and let's get the stuff
[Applause]
thank you do we have any other questions
there's still quite a few hands going up
we've got a microphone before the take
but at the back first you just raise
your hand again if you're at the back
there
over here Thanks thank you hi this is
something that was already raised
earlier on but I just wanted to get some
more clarity on it and the document
frequently states that this is not about
financial return but more about
improving the well-being and the growth
of the community my under saying from
the document is that it's mainly going
to be retail hospitality I'd like to
know if that's correct there's a lot of
other ways I could see that Invercargill
could actually promote growth and
well-being of the community than adding
more stores and restaurants I'm
completely in agreement that the CBD has
issues and needs to be improved and that
the ratepayers should contribute to this
but I think there's a lot to be added to
growth and well-being of the community
and I'd like to know if the council has
any plan of adding any extras to
actually do that than just adding shops
car parks and restaurants to that area
I suppose I I understand your question
in the broader sense and your assessment
of what is going in the development is
correct
what I
my site this stage I'm unclear of is
what you would be expecting in the
development given the nature of what it
is that isn't there
if you're talking about I mean there's
there is community space in there there
is um I understand you know obviously it
hasn't been built so we don't know how
it works out but there is the
opportunity for Vince to be held in some
other spaces as far as I understand so I
mean it's not a situation where we can
talk about the the design in the
broadest sense because that's gone
through the consent process but I'm just
struggling a little bit as to exactly
what the issue that you're trying to
identify is pro preps Andrew can you
perhaps tell the audience is the final
design and configuration of the space
been confirmed yet the designers as per
was put up and their consent and that is
to my understanding that as as it is
today I'd go further and saying that
again just as when you're building a
house things can change a little bit
along the way but I'm unaware of any
drivers for change and XW CPR waiting to
hear the determination of their consent
application okay thank you Simpson local
architect and I didn't make the
submission on this hearing so I didn't
sit through the four days of hearings I
did see that project improve during that
time some question about will it improve
it's better than it was but I started
off sort of being you tour now I've got
recently serious reservations because I
can't don't see this necessary that
demolish all the old buildings in the
block basically this proposal is well
everything except three buildings and I
think we could make better use of some
of the building anyway we'll see what
was also consensus and then we'll see
who does
all sorts of people that could appeal
the question I've got is it does on page
three the government provincial growths
but provide some funding as that funding
is that I can answer that probably would
be better than clear so that funding
obviously comes in stages the funding
was for the preparation of a business
case the business case is the business
case that has been included in the
additional materials that are available
on the council website
I sort of couldn't find it what it says
it's a feasibility
what are they say about the feasibility
of the project well but these what is he
- it was for a feasibility proposal to
be completed by a UCP and that is what
he's described as the business case on
the additional documents so what's the
outcome of that feasibility study I mean
what context sorry well that's a
reasonable investment are you saying is
it going to give a commercial return no
are they saying that there is benefits
to the community from this investment
outside the commercial return yes so you
need to be a bit more specific
how many pages a lot of times on this
jolly side and and it's not easy to
follow stuff did not apologize because
there will be some confusion around the
fact that the the grant was for a
feasibility study but I can tell you
that if you look at the business case
that's when the additional material that
is what he's turned by the PDF for the
feasibility study thank you thanks
Andrew
any further questions
thank you there's an estimate that we're
gonna need 500 people to work on the
spilled over three to four years now I
think the number of them will probably
have to come from outside of town so can
you confirm that and also if they need
to come from outside down
do we have accommodation for them and
whether the council is setting aside an
investment to create accommodation to
actually have space for people to live
if they need to come here to work on it
thank you I'm probably a better place to
into that one as well I can tell you
that that is obviously an issue that the
dispatch HWC P is working through as to
how that will occur it's not something
that council will be required to address
itself but obviously as part of the
project the unity carry on the project
will have to address those issues as to
where those people come from where
they're housed how that's achieved and
that is something that has been worked
through certain identified risks that
will be worked through thank you
yet a question the other bit I'm a rate
payer and I'm in favor of this project
but only if it includes good covered
access to hej Smith's a genius must have
been a valued and respected retailer in
this town for over a hundred years and
they've done a great deal for the city
I'm asking now this covered access
between H and Josephus possibly any
other businesses as well but also but
particularly from 18 Josephus to the new
protein thanks for that
is the someone waving to harms down the
bed
wait for a microphone is it oh yeah the
microphone sorry I just asked my name is
Natalia you probably all know me because
I've served you once a while I'm not
from here but I've been living here for
seven years and I worked in the
hospitality industry and what needs to
me I've got a lady by the name of Suzy
who owns Suzy Q now she's been not ask
you to move from her earthquake-proof
building but when she does get asked to
move where is she gonna go have you
thought about compensating the existing
businesses that do not have anywhere to
read because the rents too high or there
are no spaces there was just a proposal
of having a pop-up container ship
listeners here and won't replace and
that got the book thumbs down now that
would be a great idea just like they've
had with their precious earthquakes
there oh by the way if we had a
earthquake will we get a new CBT yeah
probably will but we need to think of
the existing retailers and businesses
that they need to find somewhere else to
be shifted for the meantime while they
can come back to the CBD while it's
being built have you considered that
thank Scalia I'm not sure whether or not
the either of the speakers here will be
able to answer there yeah look it raises
similar issues to the other person who
questioned the fact that some of the
tenants have been asked to leave their
premises already I mean as we pointed
out but there is going to be dislocation
and disruption to tenants and that's
regrettable and that's something that
needs to be managed carefully and I hope
that the case that you have pointed out
can be managed carefully I'm not sure
that we can provide you with an answer
to that tonight
yet look I'm sorry that's probably
beyond the scope of this consultation
that will be a commercial decision for
the for the dipper the ultimate
developer to make in something that we
can't answer yet the question that the
ratepayers being asked as part of this
consultation process is whether or not
you support a proposal for the council
to invest in the redevelopment of this
inner city block
yeah look I understand understand the
point you're making
I'm sorry I can't provide an answer to
that tonight but it will take that on
board Thanks
just before we come to you so anyone
else
there's a gentleman on the bed right
here yeah no question here thank you
sorry so what cup do you need
[Music]
because the way I've seen that
[Music]
yes so for those that doesn't hear that
question the question is who is going to
be managing this project because the
speaker raised concerns about the
management of the of the Todd's building
I think that's the redevelopment and
downstream the project will be managed
by HW CP or its subsequent entity the
new entity that and referred to and they
have engaged the services of a
professional project manager to manager
got a question over the back here on the
right um just as a rate payer I think
yeah it's no disagreement that we all
want to see our city torn it up to be
fair but for those of us and I
appreciate what the lady said at the bet
just keeping it real and the effect on
those who've lost now and come and have
nowhere to stay in distress in the
anxiety it's been caused to them and
those of us on low incomes and minimum
wage we have to have a guarantee that
rates are not going to go out of control
and skyrocket it has to be a guarantee
on that so that some of us aren't with
amendment
I I think the only response I could give
to that is that later this year you have
the opportunity to choose who you want
sitting around the counsel table making
decisions on the priorities projects and
consequent rate increases thanks Sofia
yes
just let's just wait for the microphone
things you said that there are a number
of private investors that would shy away
of counsel word to perhaps not that the
project that was going ahead is the
likelihood that it did go here and
private investors were prepared to
invest with that less the council's
contribution I want to be clear with you
there you're being asked whether you're
prepared to have twenty million dollars
invested any change to that shareholding
would come as a result of any subsequent
conversations but this development has
been in progress now for 18 months two
years and at this stage this is the
proposal on the table so the 30 million
that the ratepayers all contribute back
to air just where to come on board and
and this and the project as well what
they're coming reduced our deeds
I think we're back to the issue that was
asked at the beginning Rex
about where the council saw itself
staying in this for the long term and
its share of the project there are a
number of investors that have been asked
to to participate if the if there was a
private investor that came forward and
said I would like to share then of
course public investors would be happy
to say we'll we'll renegotiate our
involvement in us but I need to be clear
about the proposal that's on the table
yes so that ratepayers understand what's
being young and half way down the
project line of private obesity comes
down and see it's hey look he's she
million I think that that's that is a
possibility but I think what the council
are really saying is that in consulting
with the public on this investment
proposal it has to outline it as it
knows it now and give the community or
than the ratepayers a clear idea of what
the maximum or what the investment is
likely to be obviously if an in due
course some of them that they can sell
down some of that investment and lessen
their risk
I'm sure that's something that the
Council on the ratepayers behalf would
be would be very attracted to probably
because one of the comments made was a
council doesn't go ahead
that's in you know it's not going to
look good to private investor so I was
just wanting clarification of what you
may have in the background that you know
yeah I think there might be a little bit
of confusion there it wasn't a comment
with respect to to be clear there's no
other private investors in the wings
there are other investors but they would
be top of the Kennedy as was identified
earlier at this stage there's a southern
right down the back there I'm just
conscious that we don't know some of the
people of the back to give them an
opportunity thank you you know Rick's
just there I mean I think as a city and
as as its inhabitants I think we really
owe it to our city to give it a bit of a
a new new lease and life
give the CBD a bit of a kick in the ass
and get things moving along I also think
there as a city we we are our ratepayers
just a little bit of due diligence and a
little bit of thought into it and to see
whether we can make this thing
positively geared I mean we've got a
prime piece of real estate and
Invercargill in fact Yahoo and be
arguably one of the best bits of land in
town why can't we have it possibly be in
right now why why do we have to
subsidize it is there any way that we
could look a little bit closer under
there and perhaps come up with something
there
[Applause]
[Music]
just to be clear I don't know people use
language differently I'm assuming you're
saying why positively geared at the
return on the investment we're greater
than the cost and and what I've said all
along is that counsel's anticipation is
that that will be the case the problem
the council has in terms of the impact
on ratepayers in the short to medium
term whatever ten years whatever fee you
want to use his cash flow not return on
the investment thanks Andrew another
question you have the back of your
things thank you a couple of questions
in relation to the five million plus
that's already been invested in this
project by Council
why did council purchase that land and
participate in that that's question
number one question number two if which
is already there if we can call it an
investment because at the moment it
isn't because it's not returning
anything because they own just down to
50 percent of a rapidly emptying block
so what's gonna happen regarding that
money because what is being asked for it
is that additional council money three
what's the council's fallback or a plan
B and the event of that's not going
ahead for whatever reason whether it's
the consent process the commissioners
hearings the the decision for whatever
new information may arise that may have
a bearing on councils withdraw from this
project what happens then to that walk
that's now 60 percent vacant with a lot
of businesses that gone a whole lot of
jobs destroyed potential misplacement as
far as the remaining people are
concerned the biggest cost what you
talked about risk before and through the
risk has mostly been borne so far by the
right back
on that five million dollar investment
the risk has also been borne by the
businesses that have had to leave
already the rescue has already been
warned by the people who have lost their
investments in those businesses the
Versa has been borne by the employees
who don't have jobs anymore
like Kim Isuzu in Calvin Street a
successful business of 18 years who
closed early there's a whole stack of
unanswered questions around this thing
and nobody's asked them so I'm asking
okay well thanks for that we'll try and
break that down into those questions
that you didn't ask in summary I think
the first one was why did the council
purchase the land in the first place
clear and I'm sorry I'm not trying to
avoid the question
it wasn't the council the purchase the
land it was the property company chose
to go into partnership and create @h wcp
and it did that because in part because
of a strategy that had been developed in
Southland called sword's south and
regional development strategy and it did
that on the basis that it was asked if
it would participate join with another
in the creation of HW CP and land bank
for the purposes of a future development
and council or in the capital city
property saw the opportunity to play a
role in aggregating a number of
separately owned properties in order to
make it an attractive block ready for
development as the sword strategy had
articulated as one of its
transformational projects okay and I
think really the the series of questions
or statements that you may probably can
be wrapped into up to one other final
question and that is what's going to
happen to this land of the redevelopment
doesn't proceed what is the plan B if
I've summarized that correctly and clear
I think that my comment to that would be
that if the
doesn't go ahead I would add to that in
its current form that would depend in a
couple of a couple of different parts
the first is whether the council made a
decision to invest or not invest and
secondly there are a number of other
things such as the consent and invest or
decisions that would determine whether
Plan B was something slightly less
something slightly different or
something not happening at all in them
make short-to-medium turn I'm not able
to give you a clear answer to that
because there are a couple of balls up
in the air that until we see where
they'll end we wouldn't know what Plan B
might look like and presumably clear the
original strategy about land banking
that land would mean that the land would
still be available for salmon but the
land will continue to be owned and
partnership between with HW CP and I
think councils commitment to its CBD and
to enhancing social well-being in the
central business area would mean that
they would be looking to find an
alternative solution thank you
is there another question the thank you
my name is Rebecca I think that this is
a really good investment it's one ninth
of the investment so they the council
been asked about 20 million out of a
hundred and eighty million investment if
we don't put our investment only in the
rate payers might be able to have a
future say and potentially the design or
who goes in the building just another
thought it is it's good to hear that
it's carefully managed it won't
interfere with the long-term plan
projects my understanding is the
long-term plan is from 2018 to 2028 but
clearly you mentioned at the beginning
that that if it was prioritized and
keeping me stage it would take the next
10 to 20 years so I'm hoping that we
don't have to wait 20 years for the
long-term plan things to be coming to
fruition what was your perspective on
there and where did the 20 years come
from so are there specific projects and
that long-term plan that you're asking
about so the long-term plan is over 10
years I was an eye on my understanding
is from 20 to 18 to 20 28 but Claire
mentioned earlier that the projects
would be over from the next 10 to 20
years so I'm just not sure whether that
was a comment that
yeah I'm just curious about the 20 years
and we that come into work so the
infrastructure strategy that is part of
the long-term plan takes a longer-term
view than that
the long-term plan will be reviewed by
the new council and developed for the
period starting 2021 for the ten years
twenty twenty one to twenty thirty one
and I would stand by the comments that
on the modeling we have done today we
would be delivering the projects and the
LTP I had no hesitation that there would
go simultaneously I guess it was just
the timeframe we would be looking to
manage the projects and the finances
carefully to be able to smooth the cost
on to ratepayers and to smooth the
delivery of those projects thank you
thanks clear and I'm just conscious of
time it's getting close to seven o'clock
and yeah okay well okay yes I just have
one question and it might be a bit of a
red herring you stated clearly that the
long-term plan in this investment of it
goes ahead can work together my concern
is if the long-term plan of ten or
twenty years and I stand to be corrected
there is no planning for a backup water
system how would that implicate things
mindfully quite cheap approach at the
rate increases and things like that
am I right that there is no planning for
backup water system in the long term in
madam there was a a report put to the
Infrastructure Committee I think in the
last round of committees for the
beginning of the work for an alternative
water strategy council is very or an
alternative water source sorry
council is very mindful of the need to
undertake that work and the asset
manager has been working on that that is
something that would be included in the
infrastructure strategy that sits
alongside the LTP we will not yet know
the full costs of that but we have
certain there's some preliminary budget
for the beginning of that work
thank you that's reassuring to hear
gentlemen and the Monroe here hi Nathan
surrender again sorry I've had one bites
at the cherry him being a bit cheeky but
then I'll start by saying we're proud
south and resident V only nine years and
I chose to raise my kids here I want
this money to raise their future
prospects I would like the CEO to be
more precise in the use of words and she
stated a couple of times
eat ICC has a 50% holding it's actually
a 49.9% holding which gives the hwr
group a a controlling vote and that's
the point of my raising that with her I
agree that something does need to be do
with the CBD and actually I don't think
that 1.2 percent on the rates is
unreasonable for a project like this I
guess my concern remains the 20th
century thinking you know and the
commentators say the global retail
apocalypse is ongoing and there's best
practice around the world that mixed-use
developments walkable CBDs with
residential property incorporated as
perilous document are indicated as best
practice and fit for the future and
well-being is not just retail
hospitality retail hospitality jobs are
really quite meaningless and David
Graeber [ __ ] jobs but then anyway is
there consideration given to the brief
in the brief apologies to potential
future users and flexibility of the
space given that it's likely that the
shopping mall as they are all over the
world is going to be a failure because
you know retail is struggling globally
and will continue to do so
look I don't know just at this stage if
you want to have a look at the work
that's gone into the development to date
all that material and think is available
in their supplementary documents I
appreciate that's a lot of reading but
all the consideration around the issues
that you're raising has been taken into
account and thought through in coming up
with the proposal look I'm certain that
the people who are actually putting
their own money into this project will
be wanting to ensure that they the
development has some resilience about it
and longevity and so I'm sure that the
develop things that you've raised are
things that they will have no doubt
taken into consideration in the design
but I don't think we can provide any
further detail of this meeting thank you
and do we have another there's a
gentleman in the front here Thanks
battery don't flatten
we'll try the alternative microphone so
I just wanted to say I'm before I leave
that uh connect hearing with you a
little but with some of the attitudes in
the room I was very heartened to see
that 80% of the hands didn't go up and
were asked for show of hands early on
who didn't some who didn't support this
project I just wanted to say to the
council management team and the CEO and
the councillors that there's a ratepayer
and as a business owner in the city I I
really take my head off to having the
guts to to invest in this project and I
think that is the general opinion off
the public I appreciate is some concerns
around some of the recent investments
but I think we've got a new CEO on a new
management team which gives me courage
that they won't happen again
um the other thing I wanted to point out
was that I feel for the people this has
been raised that have been affected by
this change but as a business owner I
think we have to accept that being
businesses at risk I think it's
important that the people of the city
don't you have their judgment clouded of
this by the impact by the current
tenants as a business owner and our
family business we've had the
devastation of a factory fire taking our
business at the ground we've heard that
change that the impact of the cottage
earthquakes head and this the risk you
take when you're in business so I think
we need to be careful as ratepayers and
citizens that the council was not a
charity in that sense if you choose to
be a tenant in the CBD and things
changed it's a risk you take in business
so I think businesses rise and fall on
their own merits I just wanted to thank
the council for having the guts to back
this and I'd like to thank those
including the Community Trust and others
that wanted a back this as a as a run a
genuine project that will take us city
into the future for my children and my
grandchildren
thank you is there any other questions
on just once again conscious of time at
7 o'clock we've had people in this very
hot room for quite a long time so I'm
just going to is there any other
questions of the back otherwise we have
one at the front would you like to
proceed well yeah I just like to wish
for you there's only one thing my
husband when he was younger and the lady
next to me as a designer and her own
business but anyway I just like to say
how all the buildings nearly all of them
[Music]
there are some shops that the hip
rotated and was nothing absolutely
nothing wrong with them
there are modern and design Caroline Eve
met pep in the jeweler shops and E
Street so I could may not have been left
through those people and just the real
rocky ones shall I say and you could
have used them I mean look I'm sorry
they tell me
I don't think we can answer that
question that works well know that the
we have the CEO in the general manager
of whole code those decisions about the
management of this project really live
with the company that has been involved
in it now the council as a shareholder
their company but not actively involved
in the management of it and so on I'm
not trying to avoid the question I'm
just simply saying we haven't got the
people here that can answer okay well we
we started to get some empty seats and I
just want to bring the meeting to a
close that really want to sincerely
thank you on behalf of the council for
turning out tonight we've had some very
good balanced feedback and that's
exactly what this meeting was designed
for our perhaps just handed over to
clear just for the last word to say
thank you to you very much for sharing
tonight and I will encourage you all to
put in a submission and to share with
council your views on this proposed
investment okay thanks very much for
dinner
[Applause]